alex is in Kalamazoo hi Alex welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks for
having me
sure what's up so my wife and I are
currently on baby step number two I've
taken a new position that requires me to
travel a lot throughout the area and my
company offers a vehicle reimbursement
program to buy a new vehicle so I went
out and bought a brand new vehicle and
am currently receiving a monthly stipend
from the company to basically pay for
the vehicle payment so the notes in my
name that the company pays me monthly
I'm wondering if I should just continue
to take this payment monthly and put it
towards the vehicle or if we should
buckle down and pay this vehicle off as
fast as possible and just the company
continue to pay me that stipend okay how
much do you own the vehicle about 38,000
good lord
and what's your household income $95,000
okay and how much and you said you're
married yep and what is the value of
your wife's vehicle hers is probably
about 15,000 okay all right and and you
have thirty eight thousand dollars in
debt on this car and what other debts do
you have not counting your home less
than a thousand on a credit card that
we're just about to pay off her student
loans which are I think right around
sixteen or seventeen thousand and that's
it okay all right a couple of things
that that broke down here one is you get
a vehicle stipend whether you have a car
payment or not that's how I understood
it is that I go out and buy the no no no
you misunderstand
oh you either they are asking you to use
your car for work and so they are giving
you a vehicle stipend they did not
require you to have a payment
in order to get the vehicle stipend so
if the car were paid off in cash you
would still be getting the stipend
mm-hmm okay
and so you connected those two things
though and use that as an excuse to
ridiculously over by own car so are you
um are you bi are you driving a lot of
miles I am I am part of the the
stipulation for the company to be
eligible for the program's the car has
to be within four model years of being
new you know to be eligible for that
vehicle reimbursement and you don't
think you could do is that cheaper in
thirty eight thousand uh probably did
that for about fifteen thousand I did
that I'd be buying a new vehicle every
year or two to stay so within that
reimbursement true yeah so here's the
thing you're about to turn thirty eight
thousand into eight thousand so fast
you're gonna blink because what the
miles you're putting on a car you are
destroying the value of the car and
you're not only destroying the value of
a car you're destroying in your case the
value of an expensive car whatever you
drive you're going to destroy its value
because the model should put on it your
Road lawyer and so your you know this is
a business transaction this is not
impressing a girl to stoplight this is a
business transaction and so you want to
lose as little money on vehicles that
you are destroying their value as
possible and still get the job done now
we've got three things that are required
for you to get the job done one is it
has to be reliable two is you spend a
lot of time in the car it's got to be
reasonably comfortable we're not putting
your butt in a smart car that'd be dumb
okay you'd be in the chiropractor's
office as much time as you spend in the
car so he's got to be reasonably
comfortable it's got to be reliable and
the company has said it has to be within
four model years and so if I'm in your
shoes financially I'm gonna buy a nice
little Ford Taurus Honda or Honda Acura
something that gets good gas mileage
that is three model years old and I'm
gonna roll that puppy once a year
and because you're destroying its value
and I'm gonna put all this company money
in my pocket as I'm doing that because
what if you buy a fifteen thousand
dollar car a year later it's worth ten
if you buy forty thousand dollar car a
year later it's gonna be worth twenty
because the miles are putting on it go
do a little bit of research on your car
three years from now with the miles
you're putting on it value pick up your
car that you're driving today what is it
what kind of car hello hello well I
guess that doesn't work okay sometimes
I'm just talking to myself open phones
that triple eight eight two five five
two two five so Road boyers there's
their principal okay you are not
required to go into debt to take your
company's car stipend and you don't want
to do that that's not a plan you want to
drive the leased car possible and that's
you can't drive a hoopty in this
situation and and the goal is save up
and pay cash for it the other thing that
Alex is violating is that he has more
than half his annual income tied up in
things with wheels and motors things
with wheels and motors are the most
expensive things we buy as consumers
that go down in value and they all go
down in value boats cars lawn tractors
sea-doos four-wheelers motorcycles
trucks all go down in value you don't
get rich tying up a large substantial
amount of your money in things that are
going the wrong way so when you make
ninety five thousand dollars a year you
don't need more than $47,000 tied up in
things that are going down in value and
he has ten thousand more than that
fifteen on his wife's car 30 so 30 eight
on his car and so he's $8,000 over that
which tells me so so basically what
happened is is he had the Opera he he
saw
extra income oh by the way when your
company fires you or you quit because
they don't have integrity that car
stipend stops and your car payment
doesn't so they are not paying for your
car they didn't sign the car note you
did you took all this risk you're the
one taking the butt-kicking on this car
going down in value while you do your
job for them and they're not giving you
enough money to offset that so hope that
helps you stay away from car debt stay
away from cars things with motors and
wheels that equal more than half your
annual income and if you get a company
stipend buy the lead it cuz you're a
road warrior by the least possible car
that will get the job done
reliable and reasonably comfortable and
used
[Music]